The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Welcome
to the metabolism portion
of Biological Chemistry 5.07.
My name is John
Essigman and I teach
this course with JoAnne Stubbe.
I'm primarily a
chalkboard teacher,
as you'll notice from my notes.
In order to make things
as simple as possible,
I use a lot of abbreviations,
and my abbreviations list
will be appended elsewhere.
Let's start by looking at
a metabolic chart, figure
16-1 from the textbook.
Obviously it looks very complex.
Part of the challenge of
both teaching and learning
biochemistry is
finding a way to look
at this pig's breakfast
of biochemical reactions
and find its
underlying structure.
For the purpose of this course,
the underlying structure
we're going to look for is
the biochemical pathways
that let us function.
For example, a pathway
could involve making ATP
or it could be putting an amino
group onto an alpha-keto acid
in order to make an amino acid.
Although few people think
of biochemistry as simple,
formatting the pig's
breakfast into pathways
that have functional meaning
helps us simplify them and make
them easier to remember.
The second simplifying point is
that all biochemical pathways
are reversible.
The gray vertical bar in
the middle of this figure
is the biochemical
pathway of glycolysis
going from glucose to pyruvate.
There are 10 steps.
Some of these steps
have a negative delta
G. That is, they are favorable
in the direction drawn,
and some of them
have a positive delta
G. That is, those
steps are favorable
in the opposite direction.
But overall, when
you sum them up,
all of the free energies
of the glycolitic pathway,
you get a negative
number, which means
that the pathway of glycolysis
is overall thermodynamically
irreversible, and progresses
from glucose to pyryvate.
It turns out that there's
another pathway called
gluconeogenesis.
That pathway involves taking
non carbohydrate precursors,
such as pyruvate--
that's just one
example molecule--
and converting that
precursor to glucose.
In other words,
gluconeogenesis, in effect,
is the reverse of glycolysis.
As I said, the pathway going
from glucose down to pyruvate
is exergonic.
So what about the pathway
from pyruvate up to glucose?
In order to make the pathway
go from pyruvate to glucose,
what nature did was invent
several biochemical steps that
are highly exergonic.
That is, what we'll
see is they're
going to require ATP or some
other form of energy input
in order to make the entire
pathway of gluconeogeneisis
exergonic, as is
required of all pathways.
So we can indeed convert
pyruvate to glucose,
but it will require
energy input to make
the pathway of gluconeogenesis
have a net negative delta
G. That is, be favorable.
The third thing that actually
makes biochemistry tractable
is the fact that nature uses
only a very limited repertoire
of chemical reactions.
JoAnne showed us that
despite the complexity
of this overall
metabolic chart, there
are only about nine or 10
discrete chemical reactions
that nature uses.
So, at any given step, for
example, in glycolysis,
you really only have
about nine or 10 options,
and of that nine or 10,
only about one or two,
perhaps three, would be
chemically reasonable.
If you know your organic
chemistry and these nine or 10
reaction types, you
should be able to navigate
the biochemical chart
with comparative ease.
The fourth point
I wanted to make
is perhaps one of
the most important.
It's that all biochemical
pathways are regulated.
Chaos would result,
for example, if you
made glucose and
at the same time
took that molecule of
glucose and degraded it.
That's an example of what
we call a futile cycle.
Sometimes futile cycles can
be beneficial to a cell.
For example, that could be
a way of generating heat,
but most of the time
we want to avoid them.
Because we usually want
to avoid futile cycles,
nature uses pathway
regulation to avoid them.
To provide directionality to
pathways, what nature does
is work thermodynamically
irreversible steps
into the front and back
end of the pathway.
Sometimes nature puts
in an irreversible step
in the middle of a
pathway if that pathway
has a branch point.
That happens with
glycolysis, as we'll see.
Sometimes regulation
is effected by putting
covalent functionalities,
such as a phosphate,
onto an amino acid on a protein.
That modification could
increase or decrease
the biochemical activity
of that protein.
Often a phosphorylated
protein is highly active,
turning on a pathway, and
it is dephosphorylated
when the pathway needs
to be turned off.
A second way to regulate
a step in the pathway
is by allosteric regulation
of the enzymes of the pathway.
In that case, a small molecule
will interact with the enzyme
in order to increase or
decrease its activity.
JoAnne taught us about
allostery when she taught us
how hemoglobin is regulated.
To reiterate, nature uses
these regulatable C enzymes
at key places and overall
metabolic pathways
to enable us to
be able to achieve
the function of the
pathway without wasting
energy or resources.
The last introductory
point I want to make
is that all biochemical
pathways tend
to be compartmentalized, at
least in mammalian cells,
although it's increasingly
becoming obvious that even
in bacteria there is some
form of compartmentalization.
That is, clustering of enzymes
for a particular pathway
in a particular
area of the cell.
For example, in
a mammalian cell,
the mitochondrian is the site
of fatty acid beta-oxidation,
or break down.
The tricarboxylic
acid cycle and enzymes
of the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex are also mitochondrial.
The cytoplasm is the site where
we do fatty acid biosynthesis,
most of gluconeogenesis,
glycolysis,
and the pentose
phosphate pathway.
Compartmentalisation helps
keep the metabolic chart
tidy and organized.
With that in the way
of an introduction,
let's turn to my lecture
notes, which I present
in the format of storyboards.
In the first
storyboard, panel A,
I give the definition
of metabolism
as the linked set of
biochemical reactions
by which we obtain
and use free energy.
That is, delta G, for life.
We use that free energy
for a lot of things,
but the use is really
divide into three areas.
The first is to do
mechanical work,
the second is to generate
concentration gradients,
and the third is
for biosynthesis.
In a few minutes, I'm
going to be giving you
an example of all three.
Panel B. Biochemists
divide metabolism
into two subcategories.
Catabolism and anabolism.
Briefly, catabolism consists of
the energy yielding pathways,
and anabolism is
basically biosynthesis.
We use the free energy that
we generate through catabolism
in order to assemble complex
molecules by way of anabolism.
Let's look at panel
C. We're going
to start 5.07 with a
discussion of catabolism.
That is the energy
yielding pathways.
By way of definitions,
a reduced molecule
is one that is abundantly
supplied with electrons.
Examples are carbohydrates,
fats, and proteins.
These are typically our foods.
The process of
catabolism involves
finding a way to liberate the
electrons from those reduced
substances and transfer those
electrons to mobile electron
carriers, such as
NAD-plus to form NADH,
or NADP-plus to form NADPH.
The process by which electrons
are removed from a molecule
is called oxidation, and
the oxidation products
are, for example, carbon
dioxide that we breathe out,
or in some organisms, lactate,
or other simple molecules
that are excreted.
Simple, that is, compared to
the complex reduced molecules
that we consume as food.
NADH and FADH2, molecules
that JoAnne taught us,
are what I'll refer to as
mobile electron carriers.
They can usually move
around inside the cell,
although sometimes they're
embedded within enzymes.
That is usually the
case with FADH2.
We consume an enormously large
number of reduced substances
due to the complexities
of our diets,
and catabolism involves
taking the electrons out
of this enormously vast
array of substrates
and transferring those electrons
to a small number of reduced
electron carriers.
For example, NAD or flavins.
In the process of respiration,
which we'll come to later,
the electrons are further
transferred from the reduced
electron carriers all the
way to molecular oxygen.
The reduction of
molecular oxygen
is a highly exothermic reaction.
We're going to be able
to use the energy that's
generated by oxygen reduction
in order to make ATP,
and to do some other important
biochemical activities.
Now I'm going to introduce
a physiological scenario
and use it in order to introduce
the pathway of glycolysis.
In class at this
point, I usually
ask a student to
stand up and sit down.
As you can imagine,
being called on in class
creates more than a little
bit of anxiety in the student.
Let's look at panel D. The
signal to stand up and sit down
is processed by the brain,
and an electrical signal then
goes by the nerves to the
muscles enabling the student
to stand up.
The anxiety of being called on
by the teacher in class results
in a nervous excitation
of the adrenal gland,
specifically in the adrenal
medulla, which releases
epinephrine.
Epinephrine is also
known as adrenaline.
It goes to the muscles as well
as other organs of the body,
as we'll see later in 5.07.
And the epinephrine will
interact at cell membranes
by way of
transmembrane receptors
in order to turn on
pathways of catabolism,
in order to generate
the ATP that's
needed to help the student deal
with this stressful situation.
This is sometimes called the
fight or flight response.
At this point in the class, if
I really wanted to make my point
and have it transferred
to every student,
I'd announce a pop quiz.
The announcement
of a pop quiz would
cause kind of this cold
feeling throughout your gut.
That's actually the feeling of
adrenaline preparing your body
to deal with the stress
situation, in that case,
of the quiz.
Let's look at panel E. As
the scenario progresses,
let me introduce a few
biochemical players.
Glycogen phosphorylase,
glucose, glucose six phosphate,
and glucose one phosphate.
In panel F we see a muscle cell.
The epinephrine in
the blood is only
going to reach a
concentration of about 10
to the minus 10 molar.
That's a very, very
low concentration.
The epinephrine is
going to interact
at the beta and alpha adrenergic
receptors in the muscle cell
membrane.
This interaction results
in the activation
of a kinase, that
is a molecule that
transfers a phosphate group.
And that kinase, which is called
SPK, for synthase phosphorylase
kinase, phosphorylate serine
14 on glycogen phosphorylase.
Phosphorylation activates
glycogen phosphorylase,
which will then begin
to degrade glycogen--
the polymeric storage form
of glucose in us, that is,
mammals--
to produce initially
glucose one phosphate.
Glucose one phosphate
will then go
through a number
of transformations
and eventually be converted
into other forms of glucose
and then other molecules
that will generate energy.
In a nutshell, this stand
up, sit down scenario results
in the generation of
energy in a matter
of seconds which is
one of the things
that we use metabolism for.
Another thing I said earlier was
that you use metabolic energy
to generate
concentration gradients.
And it turns out that generation
of concentration gradients
is absolutely critical
for muscle activity.
The sarcoplasmic reticulum
in our muscle cells
must accumulate calcium and
release it at precisely defined
moments in order to enable
the muscle to be able to work.
That concentration grading
of calcium has to be created,
and it's created with the energy
that we get from metabolism.
Again, we'll see how
calcium gradients help boot
up energy generation
in the last lecture,
which deals with
pathway regulation.